à haut rhin soutien à tapas podovani
jeter saget natacha
intimes vous investir mais sur le
logement
avant la guerre avec la russie sacha
diriger sa propre agence d'événementiel
actuellement avec son fils il se sert de
sa fourgonnette pour transporter de
l'eau à travers nikolaïev
depuis près de trois semaines la
majorité des habitants font la queue
devant les différents points de
distribution de la ville pour se
ravitailler en eau ceux qui ne peuvent
pas se débrouiller seuls doivent compter
sur l'aide des bénévoles comme sacha
pour tatiana ce coup de main est une
aubaine
j'ai une maladie qui a atteint mon
système nerveux et qui n'empêche de
bouger
je peux me déplacer un peu dans
l'appartement mais sortir mais difficile
les voisins de tatiana après avoir
aperçu sacha lui demandent à leur tour
le même service
sacha travailler main dans la main avec
une association de bénévoles connu sous
le nom de dof elle a vu le jour après
que le gouvernement ukrainien et
demander aux citoyens tout début de la
guerre de l'aider à construire des check
points et à fabriquer des cocktails
molotov
depuis quatre cents personnes ont
rejoint l'association qui reçoit des
dons venant d'ukraine et de l'étranger
d'offres répond à tous les besoins quels
qu'ils soient y compris ceux venant des
volontaires de la défense territoriale
c'est le cas de cet ancien combattant
qui a servi en afghanistan et qui met
actuellement son expérience militaire au
profit de sa vie
le gouvernement nous aide du mieux qu'il
peut mais il ya des interruptions donc
nous avons besoin de nourriture ne
conserve de vêtements d'uniformes
kaki
pour ses défenseurs de nikolaev un tel
soutien ne peut que leur remonter le
moral
bien sûr cela vous rend heureux quand
vous voyez que la jeune génération et
six patriotes quand ils laissent tout de
côté viennent travailler quand ils
chargent livres font des choses cela
montre que l'ukraine va prospérer que
nous vaincrons
cette activité se poursuit à l'intérieur
du bâtiment où les volontaires se sont
installés compte tenu de sa proximité
avec le front mikolaj accueille beaucoup
de déplacés qui arrivent avec de maigres
bagages
nous trions fonction des commandes
c'est pour une fille de 7 ans et un
garçon de 4 ans
hier nous avons des commandes comme
celle ci qui nous indique la taille
pour les réfugiés et pour les personnes
dans le besoin
ces besoins nous concerne pas que les
vêtements une autre partie du bâtiment
abrite une pharmacie de fortune où
quelques bénévoles avec une expérience
médicale essaye de se rendre utile mais
avec la poursuite des combats il n'est
pas toujours facile de répondre à toutes
les demandes
nous avons vraiment besoin de trousse de
premiers soins tactique pour nos gars
qui se battent nous avons besoin de gars
autour nique et nous avons besoin
d'anesthésiant en particulier
injectables nous avons besoin de
pansements hémostatique d'urgence et
deux substituts sanguins
si un matériel technique comme celui ci
est difficile à trouver les bénévoles
peuvent au moins aider à remonter le
moral de ceux qui sont sur le front
autrefois photographe irina prépare des
autocollants dessinés à la main et
destinés à être placés dans des colis
qui seront envoyés aux troubles
ukrainienne
n'est pas nouvelle mais c'est la mienne
pour rendre les soldats plus heureux il
recevrait au moins des autocollants ou
une carte postale
l'homme derrière l'association d'geof et
vladimir un pianiste au jazz qui espère
que son association survivra aux comptes
actuel
même si ce lieu est aujourd'hui à moitié
en ruine dans deux ans il aura 200 ans
et nous espérons avoir la possibilité de
le restaurer nous espérons que la guerre
se terminera et que nous pourrons
célébrer notre victoire
[Musique]
la première victoire de nikolay se
trouvent dans des efforts que les
volontaires ont réussi à mettre en place
à travers de tels projets et avec
l'ambition russe d'avancer vers le sud
de l'ukraine considéré comme une cible
majeure on s'apprête ici à faire face à
des jours plus difficiles